Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is as fresh as it gets. As of
making of this video it has been out for
only one day and I got so excited about
it that I wanted to show it to you
Fellow Scholars as soon as humanly possible because you've got to see this.
Not so long ago we have been talking
about deep neural networks,
the technique that was inspired by the
human visual system.
It enables computers to learn things in
a very similar way that the human would.
There is a previous two minute papers
episode on this. Just click on the
link in the description box if you've
missed it. Neural networks are by no
means perfect so do not worry,
don't quit your job, you're good, but some
applications are getting out of control.
In Google Deep Mind's case is started to
learn playing simple computer games and
eventually showed a superhuman level
plays in some cases. I have run this
piece of code and got some pretty sweet
results that you can check out. There is
a link to it in the description box as
well.
So about this paper we have here today,
what does this one do? You take
photographs with your camera and you can
assign it any painting and it will apply
this painting's artistic style to it. You
can add the artistic style of Vincent
van Gogh's beautiful "Starry Night" to it and get some gorgeous results. Or, if you
are looking for a bit more emotional or
may I say disturbed look you can go for
Edvard Munch's "The Scream" for some
stunning results. And of course the
mandatory Picasso. So as you can see
deep neural networks are capable of
amazing things and we expect even more
revolutionary works in the very near future.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time!